this evening I have the pleasure of
introducing Miss grace Murray Turner she
is the president and founder of the
Galen Institute and founder of the
health policy consensus group she is a
recipient of the 2007 outstanding
achievement award for promotion of
consumer driven health care from
consumer health world founder and
president of our natin cup company a
health policy analysis firm
miss Turner testifies regularly before
Congress and and in 2013 was named by
Speaker of the House to serve as a
member of the long-term care Commission
she has written for numerous
publications including The Wall Street
Journal the New York Times and the USA
in USA Today and has appeared on many
television and radio show shows
including ABC's 20/20 she is she is
co-author of why Obamacare is wrong for
America and editor for empowering health
care consumers through tax reform please
all join me in welcoming grace to the
stand
[Applause]
hello everyone thank you so much for
coming out on this rainy afternoon and
even more for inviting me to Hillsdale
this is my first chance to visit this
really famous campus that I have admired
from afar for such a long time and I
really am grateful to be with you here
today to talk with you about health
policy and how we can sort out the mess
that we are in I think those PJ O'Rourke
who said you think health care is
expensive now just wait until it's free
absolutely true thank you Bernie Sanders
just in case you want to wonder what's
going on so just a little talk about
where we are and the stage setter
there's really not a lot of disagreement
about the goals of health reform we want
to make sure that everybody has health
coverage we want to make sure that the
health care and coverage are both
affordable we want to make sure that
that's what they're we have good quality
of care and we also want to make sure
that people have choices if you like
your doctor you can keep your doctor if
you like your coverage you can keep your
coverage and I think most importantly as
Americans we want to make sure that the
most vulnerable in our society have
opportunities to get the care that they
need so how are we doing with that
not so well the Congressional Budget
Office just released some new data that
I think puts it in a larger perspective
particularly for young people today who
are going to be inheriting mountains of
debt from the entitlement programs that
we have today and I think under swill
give some indication of why it's so
important for us to do health reform
when you look at this this chart you can
see how much of the federal budget the
photo of the federal budget and also our
health sector is currently being
financed through government programs we
spend about three point one trillion
dollars this year on health care
almost half of it goes through
government programs
Medicare Medicaid and the Children's
Health Insurance primarily but also the
Veterans Administration the Indian
Health admitted that Indian Health
Service and only half is financed
through private programs but when you
look at this you can also see that the
small percentage I used to have a
pointer here the small percentage that
consumers actually pay out of their own
pocket 11% they're financing the whole
thing through taxes through reductions
in their wages through deficit spending
but only 11% actually comes directly out
of their pocket and I out-of-pocket
expenditures so imagine if we had an
automobile industry where people only
paid 11% of the cost and by the way had
no idea how much it was going to be
before they spent the money
what a mess we'd have and people being
able to buy it purchase an affordable
automobile well that's that's really
where we are in our health sector and
one of the reasons that we've got to get
it back to more of a market-based system
and we'll talk a little bit about how to
do that so this is this is again a new
CBO chart that shows how dramatically
important it is to begin to reduce even
just a bit the spending on health care
if we were to keep prices this is over
the long-term thinking about this until
2045 is the date here sorry I have to
look at this that if they were to if
health costs were to grow at just 1% or
lower then the rate of what they call
excess growth on federal spending on
Medicare and Medicaid was grown by a 109
percent over the next couple of several
decades if it grows at 1% or higher it's
double that it cause up to two hundred
and six percent so just a small
reduction in spending can make a huge
difference over time in what this does
of the federal deficit and look at this
the projection
of where we are with federal debt held
by the public this goes back all the way
to the beginning of the country and you
can see in 1790 after the Revolutionary
War there is a pretty significant debt
held by the public
the spikes you see or the civil war a
World War one the recession World War
two but look where we are now where
we're headed and this is almost
exclusively because of entitlement
spending entitlement spending and debt
payment financing the debt so we really
must address this and Obamacare cook
took us completely in the wrong
direction as you will see as you already
know but it's all have some some data to
show you so we've got to begin to move
the needle back toward individuals
controlling more of their choices but
importantly having incentive to spend
those tax dollars and those health care
dollars wisely so we don't add to the
mountains of debt that we are facing
that really do I believe compromise the
future of our freedom and our liberty in
this country so let's drill down a
little bit now and talk about the the
Obamacare world and what has happened
over the last really decade because we
started this debate in 2007-2008
over-over health reform and what this is
mean it going to mean to our to our
country so you know you have to
acknowledge that there has been a major
reduction in the number of people
without health insurance we started out
with 44 million people not having health
insurance before the Affordable Care Act
Obamacare passed and in 2016 we had 28
million people who were uninsured so
that's a net reduction of 16 million
people in that word that previously were
uninsured that are not now so that's us
you know you could argue a significant
public policy achievement do they have
access to care not necessarily but they
do have an insurance card and look where
the major cover
Ridge has come from almost exclusively
from expansion of Medicaid a lot of
people lost their private health
insurance both their individual policies
even in their job-based coverage
particularly in the people that worked
for small companies but the net increase
almost 90 percent of the net increase in
new coverage was through Medicaid
another entitlement program that has to
be financed through a deficit spending
and through higher taxes and when you
look at what did this do to private
coverage well in the Obamacare exchanges
where people can get private health
insurance this is apart from Medicaid
yet about 9 million people getting
subsidies to purchase health insurance
through the exchanges you had another 9
million people that we're getting
coverage in the individual market this
required
mandated coverage under Obamacare but
they weren't getting subsidies those are
the people who are really ticked off
right now because of the huge huge costs
increases that they're facing in their
coverage but remember they're mandated
to buy it so either they pay that or
they pay thank you john roberts attacks
about three and a half million people
lost job based coverage Walmart for
example looked at the numbers and
Walmart a good company that it was doing
a lot to provide options for people in
getting good health insurance coverage
they basically said to part-time workers
you're better off in the exchanges
because you're going to get a lot more
help with your insurance premiums if you
go into the exchanges so we're dropping
coverage for part-time people many of
them even on Medicaid the net increase
in coverage in private health insurance
coverage for all of the turmoil that we
have gone through over the last eight
ten years 1.7 million more people that I
have private cover
than did before there surely had to be a
better way to go about doing this and
we're gonna talk about that the
individual mandate this was the mandate
that was but truly is the most unpopular
part of this law and the one that most
challenges our freedom on to see some
heads nodding that tells you that the
federal government is going to determine
how you are how you are going to spend a
significant and growing part of your
personal income on a product a private
product that the government forces you
to purchase we and many others wrote
amicus briefs when the Supreme Court was
arguing this case saying this is
unconstitutional but Judge Roberts says
no it's tax and therefore the government
does have a choice you can either buy
the insurance or pay a tax so you have a
choice well for a lot of people that's
not much of a choice I had an uber
driver recently who said that he had
taken this part-time job because it was
the only way he could afford health
insurance for his family he said my
health insurance now cost more than my
mortgage does and people are finding
that increasingly they ignore so to talk
about costs in a minute but the cost of
health insurance are increasing
dramatically that people are now
required to buy this hugely expensive
policy that is getting more and more
expensive and it's not an option they
have to purchase it by our pay a fine
Congress gets it and has tried four
times to try to get reform legislation
over the top and I'm going to talk with
you in a minute about what was in those
bills such as probably going to be news
to you based upon the way that it the
news coverage are those bills but it is
that they really can't give up I believe
they do obviously they are and should be
focused on tax reform right now but I
believe they have to come back to this
issue in 2018 to try again and we're
working very hard to try to put together
a product that learns from the lessons
of the last year so that we can shape
product.this health insurance
legislation in a way I see a head
nodding they're going to do that they
have to the reason they have to do this
is and I have actually talked with with
members who said I am going to be
primary by people who are Stella saying
that I failed to get Obamacare repeal
legislation through Congress and they
need to elect them a different
Republican to pass this legislation so
they are and those primaries happen in
the first part of next year and they
certainly don't want to go to the voters
next fall and say you know it was we
told you for 4 election cycles we were
going to repeal Obamacare it was just
too hard I can't do that they have to
try again and this time with the bottom
up process where people feel more
engaged the leadership felt it was so
important to get Obamacare repeal and
replace legislation through that the
leadership ran this from the top down
and we're going to get this perfect
we're going to get this legislation
exactly right but the members did not
feel engaged they couldn't explain it
say they were as vulnerable as the
American people were to hearing about
small parts of the legislation not
understanding the bigger picture of what
it would do and then finally John McCain
with his thumbs down killed the whole
effort so we but we're coming back at it
we're going to do this so the reason we
have to do it is because the American
people are hurting more than ever over
this legislation in since 2003 2013
that's the year before the Obamacare
exchanges the mandates went into effect
premiums have risen 99 percent for
individuals a hundred and forty percent
for families and that's on average costs
for a 27 year old let's say it just got
off your parents policies the 26 year
old had parents who had health insurance
at work kept him on the policy he would
have spent
about $2,600 for a policy the first year
of Obamacare this year 4900 what 27 year
old just starting out it's going to be
able to afford
$2,700 in premiums probably without much
help from the federal government and
paying them and in any case that's too
much money for health insurance young
people are being forced to pay a much
higher percentage of the cost of
expansion of health insurance than older
people they made a decision oh we're
going to just make the 27 year olds pay
more so we can charge 55 60 year-olds
less if completely unbalanced as far as
the resources that that 26 or 27 year
old has the average price includes the
average price increase for coverage this
year is 37 percent a one-year for 2018
and many people are not going to have a
choice of plans they're gonna have a
sort of a take-it-or-leave-it plan in
your area if they're lucky they may have
two choices in HMO and one of the health
insurance companies that are all cookie
cutter plans anyway because they're all
defined by the federal government this
is shows in 2015 only 6% of people lived
in counties that only had a choice of
one insurer but by 2017 33 percent did
and next year it's going to be about
half of people live in counties where
they really don't have a choice by this
health insurance that the federal
government is making you too bought by
or pay a fine this is not okay they have
to come back at this
so here what about their what is their
plan well this year they thought we just
have to pass something even if it was if
it's not perfect let's get something
through the market stabilization I think
that's probably this is the bipartisan
bill that Senator Alexander from
Tennessee Republican and Senator Murray
from Washington State Democrat are
trying to put together I don't think
that's going to go anywhere but as I
said I do believe they're going to
return to repeal and
pays legislation in 2018 but also behind
the scenes there's a lot going on with
regulatory action this this bill and the
slide I'll show you in a minute this
bill gave the Secretary of Health and
Human Services 2,000 different powers to
run our health section and that was not
good news under the Obama administration
but the Trump administration there are
good smart staffers working both in the
White House and at the Department of
Health and Human Services that are
really diving down into the weeds of
these regulations and looking for opera
opportunities to roll back regulations
to use executive actions to give people
more choices and also inviting people to
come up with innovative ideas so that
they can do even more
over the next three at least years and
then Congress also is looking at the
possibility of regular order bills there
are a number of pieces of this health of
the Obamacare bill that are that it has
bipartisan opposition one is the
Independent Payment Advisory Board this
is what we called the death panel this
is where these 14 bureau bureaucrats
that have no judicial review and
basically no and no congressional review
are able to set and therefore cut prices
and Medicaid and there are a number of
Democratic leaders who say this is this
is not constitutional they cannot set
payment policy without being elected
representative so I think that's
something that we might be able to get
by part of the house actually passed on
a bipartisan basis with 44 Democrats
crossing over to pass this out of the
house a heavier lift in the Senate but I
think they'll look at that other things
like making tax credits available for
Cobra insurance this is the insurance
that you get to keep often after you
leave your employer giving TRICARE
veterans eligibility for tax credits and
doing some things for small businesses
which again have a lot of bipartisan
support so once we get past sort of the
big bulb of what we do with the with
Obamacare
I think there will be the opportunity
for other legislation I thought this if
they would have gotten this done earlier
this year we could be in that season now
it's probably going to be hard for them
to do it in an election year in 2018 but
I think they will likely come back at
this in 2019 to do some of these things
on a bipartisan basis to fix the bill
but so far not going so well car wreck
so repeal replace retain retreat what
are we going to do here the American
healthcare act finally passed the House
may 3rd Senate failed on July 28th and
the final attempt to pass a Senate bill
was pulled from the floor when they
realized Senator McCain was once again
going to vote against it as was Senator
Collins from Maine and Senator Murkowski
all Republicans basically killing the
health reform effort but this little
video seemed to really sort of capsulate
this happily happily going along just
crashed and burned that's why they need
to start this from a different direction
so let's talk though about the core
provisions of the House and Senate bills
because there were a lot of similarities
from those bills and I think that they
are likely to provide much of the
structure for health reform legislation
going forward there nobody was going to
lose their current coverage did you hear
that no both bills all of these bills in
both houses would have said if you are
receiving coverage now you're getting
health insurance many people who lost
coverage against their will the policies
were cancelled there's employers dropped
it they don't have anywhere else to go
and this coverage is much more expensive
than they can afford we cannot have them
we can't have those 16 million people
suddenly losing coverage so they would
have continued a support system for them
to be able to keep that coverage until a
new system was what have put in place it
would have preserved
the expansion of Medicaid there were
been different ways that they would have
begun to roll that back it would have
also as I said provided subsidies to
help people keep their health insurance
and just as an example in the House bill
the subsidies for health insurance for a
family would have gone up to $14,000 a
year to keep their health insurance so
they were not pulling the rug out from
the american people as the media but
would have us believe importantly they
would have repealed all of the taxes and
obamacare a trillion dollars in taxes 20
new and higher taxes would have been
repealed they would have allowed young
people to stay on their parents policies
that's sort of now a given it would have
repealed that awful individual mandate
and the employer mandate gotten rid of
them given us our freedom back also
importantly and this i think is going to
be the key provision for going forward
it would have given states a lot more
flexibility in how they spend both their
Medicaid dollars and the money that's
coming to citizens in their states to
purchase health insurance right now you
may have in a one family somebody on
employer insurance somebody on Medicaid
somebody on the children's health
insurance program somebody getting
coverage through the exchanges what a
nightmare
to try to manage all of those different
health insurance programs in one family
and how incredibly expensive and
wasteful it is to have all those siloed
programs so the states would have been
able to merge those funds at the
individual level to give people more
choices and to approve plans that mazing
ly they may actually want to buy with
these with these resources so there were
there are really good ideas in this
legislation but it hardly was able and
of course we can't forget protections
for pre-existing conditions because
that's another political given that you
have
built into your system the final bill
that didn't that just barely did not
come to the Senate for a vote in late
September was sponsored by senators
Graham Cassidy Heller Nevada and Johnson
from Wisconsin and this really came at
the issue from a different perspective
instead of having the same refundable
tax credits to distribute money at the
federal level they said you know we've
really got a we've got to move toward a
system of federalism we've got to trust
the states we've got to give them
resources and we've got to make sure
that they meet deliverables with how
they are allocating these resources but
to give them the chance to begin to
build their health care systems back up
from the bottom up it would have had no
individual mandate the penalties they
couldn't really get rid of the
individual mandate through initiative
said this earlier through this
reconciliation process in order to get
legislation through the Senate with a
simple majority vote everything in it
everything has to be directly pertinent
to federal spending or taxes if its
regulatory parliamentarian says sorry
we're thro not only throwing that out we
may throw out the whole effort so
they're walking on eggs trying to figure
out how can they do give states as much
power as they can but do it through
these financial systems the only way to
get rid of the individual mandate was to
say we can't get rid of it because it's
a regulation but we can make sure that
you don't ever have to pay a penalty for
not having health insurance more
employers would not have to pay a
penalty so that's that's how they were
through this single majority 51 vote in
the Senate mechanism going to get rid of
the individual and employer mandate
until we can elect enough people that
would actually take it off the books for
good taxes this is not good because they
basically said we're going to keep most
of those taxes we're going to keep the
medical - we're going to get rid of the
medical device tax again something that
has strong bipartisan opposition but
leave most of those other texts
it's not necessarily very good we're
working on this but importantly the
funding would devolve to the states one
of the things that we've learned through
this experience with Obamacare is the
federal government is completely out of
its element in managing something as
vast and yet personal and regional as
health care the same policies cannot
work for Missoula Montana Manhattan and
Miami Florida those are completely
different markets they might as well be
in different countries we've got to give
states and really even localities the
ability to remove those resources down
to the individual level so that people
are making choices of what works for
themselves and their families in a more
transparent system where people have
more choices than they do with this
federally mandated health insurance
coverage and give the states then some
deliverables you know how are you doing
and reducing the number of uninsured
rather than telling them every hoop
they'd have to jump through so the bill
I believe is going to be the structure
for health reform legislation going
forward that is really built on the
principle of federalism so that the
states begin to rebuild their health
insurance markets we've done some focus
group polling and people get it they say
you know federal government can't
regulate shouldn't be regulating my
health insurance I know my state
legislators or at least I feel that they
are more likely to listen to me if I go
to talk to them and they want their
states to have more more control over
the kind of policies that are available
to them but let's take a look at that
what happened in this debate because you
have to learn that in order to be able
to know going forward how do we need to
address some of the problems that we ran
into so how many people heard that if
these Republican bills were to pass 22
million people would lose health
insurance coverage
okay let's explain what that meant this
is the all-knowing Congressional Budget
Office telling us that right the
Congressional Budget Office absque ribes
almost magical powers to the individual
mandate they said that in 2018 just next
year if these bills were to pass this
year suddenly 14 million people would be
more people would be uninsured they
wouldn't lose coverage because the
subsidies weren't generous enough
remember they put $14,000 on the table
for a family no it was because the
individual mandate penalties would be
repealed and people would just stop
buying coverage five million people
would just drop out of Medicaid for most
people Medicaid cost them nothing but if
they didn't have a mandate to be covered
they drop out of Medicaid to men people
would just drop their employer-based
coverage because the mandate goes away
and six million people would lose
externally the exchanges even though
they're getting heavily subsidized
coverage in exchange makes no sense but
almost all and then the 22 million was a
2014 number almost all of the coverage
losses were because the Congressional
Budget Office believes that if we just
wait long enough the individual mandates
going to work we're going to be able to
force everybody to buy health insurance
we'll just have to make those penalties
a little bit higher until people feel
the pain it's not going to work in our
country people are dropping coverage
because they cannot afford it unless the
coverage is more affordable we're not
only going to not have be able to keep
stable health insurance markets we're
going to be begin losing cut losing the
coverage grounds they've made in fact we
already see it for next year we're gonna
see the individual market drop by two
million people just because the costs
are getting so completely out of hand so
this is just to show you exactly s'en to
the Congressional Budget Office
they thought that by twenty was that
seventeen that we would have about 25
million people in the Obamacare
exchanges these are the people buying
private coverage through healthcare.gov
in the state's version of those
subsidized health plans actual number 10
million but at the end of the year more
like eight and a half because people
will sign up for coverage in the
beginning of the year and then say you
know I just can't be paying these
premiums and then they drop out why do
they do that it's because the incentives
are if you pay your premiums through
September 30th the companies are
required to continue to provide you
coverage to the first of the year 90
days and you can by the way go back and
buy a policy from that same code that
same company for the premium you would
have paid had you stayed continuously
coverage so there was an incentive for
people to drop coverage and they did it
and there was even worse there were lots
of incentives for people to not buy the
coverage at all and wait till they're
sick to sign up which they also did
that's what guaranteed that the
guaranteed-issue provision you're gonna
be able to buy a health insurance no
policy no matter what well insurance
doesn't work if you do that but
Congressional Budget Office seem to
really ignore that so also if you were
to replace the individual mandate what
are you gonna do that with if you had
health insurance this is where the House
and Senate bills if you maintained
coverage and what we want to do health
insurance only works if people pay
premiums overtime in case they get sick
and need coverage so it would have said
if you maintain continuous coverage then
you cannot be charged more if you get
sick or injured and need to use your
health insurance they also said if we
didn't buy coverage you would face in
the House bill a 30 percent surcharge
for a year I mean it's still not a huge
premium a huge penalty to provide
coverage and the Senate said that if you
dropped coverage and didn't have it you
had to wait six months until you could
apply again I'm not sure either of those
is the right answer
I think the states actually could
probably do a better job of it figuring
out if it's gonna work we're gonna have
you know good health care's health care
system people need to participate and
how could we give them an incentive to
do it well the biggest incentive is to
make it affordable with a product they
want to buy but also maybe to have a few
sticks but not as something as ownerís
and expensive as the individual mandate
so pre-existing conditions also
everybody would have been protected they
only would have been able draught states
could only drop the pre-existing
condition protections if they had a
better idea so we also have heard people
are gonna be leaning in the streets
lying in the glut gutters bankrupt if
any of these house goes past but as you
see there were a lot of protections in
here that they got almost no credit for
as I said sake because all they waived
the pre-existing condition if they had a
better idea so what's next I think that
a lot of regulatory action is going to
be certainly it's it's not easy but it's
easier than getting a bill an act of
Congress passed clearly the president
announced an executive order last month
that I think really can begin to free up
the market expanding Association health
plans this is allowing let's say you're
a small contractor and Hills in
Hillsdale and you can't afford this you
can't afford to purchase coverage for
your six or seven workers but your
National Association may be the National
Home Builders Association offers you the
opportunity to buy into their plan where
their aggregate
lots of other small companies together
so they can get volume and quantities of
efficiencies of scale that's I think
going to be important it allowed people
to not be subject only to the
regulations in their states so sort of a
twofer it allows people to buy and
volume and also to be able to have
for regulatory structures there also and
I think this is really going to be
crucial will allow people to purchase
temporary policies the Obama
administration in order to drive more
and more people into the exchanges
basically said you can't buy a temporary
policy for more than the last for more
than three months what that meant was
that somebody who's starting his
business moving between jobs and they
don't have the operative the option for
health insurance yet couldn't buy a
policy that lasted for more than three
months see Trump administration is right
rewriting the rules so that people can
buy a policy for a year and it doesn't
it's not subject to all the rules and
regulations and mandates of Obamacare
and they're going to be able to redo it
renew it so this is a way of giving
people an option of different kinds of
health insurance that escape all of the
Obamacare rules and regulations through
this regulatory action that could I
think just explode in giving people more
opportunities and more options for
coverage and then finally allow people
to use health reimbursement arrangements
what's this sort of a precursor of
health savings accounts but based on the
employer model employer could put money
aside into a funding account and allow
people to to use that money to pay for
routine bills and therefore be able to
have a higher deductible policy but
still with the employer helping with
with the some of the out-of-pocket cost
but importantly the administration plans
to allow people to use that money to pay
for premiums which they couldn't do
before and what that means is that if
two people are working a husband and a
wife both have the offer of health
insurance at work usually they have to
decide which one to pick or sometimes
worse you may have one person on one
policy and another on the other the
children may be even honest sometimes a
separate policy this would say
you can use the money that the employer
would have set aside for your health
insurance to be able to buy one family
plan to help with the premiums you
decide that you're going to use the wife
is the wife's offer of employer-based
health insurance but the husband has a
health reimbursement arrangement at his
job they can use that money to help pay
the premiums so this is going to make
family coverage a lot more affordable
and once again people give people more
flexibility so these are just a few of
the regulatory actions that I think are
going to be possible with with this
administration actually looking to help
people in purchasing affordable coverage
imagine that rather than trying to beat
them over the head so when you look at
what is the reason once again another
reason we have to fix this you've heard
a lot about oh the Trump administration
is just stopping enrollment they're
gonna they're not going to do anything
to help people get enrolled in coverage
well the Obama administration said spend
more than 62 million dollars last year
on something cause somebody called
navigators these were people who had
often absolutely no experience with
health insurance as health insurance
brokers or health insurance agents who
were signing people up for the exchanges
they navigators enrolled 81 million
people with the sixty-two million
dollars in taxpayer money less than one
percent of the total
one grantee spent two hundred thousand
dollars and they only enrolled one a
person so would it make sense for the
Trump administration to say let's just
keep that program going absolutely not
and so they cut it in half oh my
goodness you would have thought that
they cut people's arms off and it was
just awful think the the reaction to
stopping this wasteful spending on
navigators but they put a button on
healthcare.gov and they said if you want
to talk to a private insurance who
private insurer our private agent
who by the way may actually know
something about health insurance click
here and you'll be referred to somebody
who actually knows about health
insurance who can help you enroll and it
doesn't cost the federal government
anything so there are better ideas out
there 78% of these navigators failed to
meet their enrollment goals and so as I
said they're cutting it in half and I
think probably it's not going to affect
enrollment at all and actually may help
by having private agents providing to
help help with them so the final bottom
line is that we've got to return power
to the states we've got to be able to do
that and it's going to require a change
in federal law it's quite a chain really
care and redirecting some of these
subsidies and re doing a better job than
Brent Graham Cassidy did of figuring out
how to do that to give the state's more
authority and there actually is a
provision in Obamacare which can't be
repealed because it's a regulation not a
taxing and spending directly directly
attributable distraction sitting called
section 1332 you're gonna hear that's a
section of the law it's about a page and
a half out of the twenty seven hundred
pages of legislation in Obamacare which
by the way has spawned about fifty
thousand pages of regulation this is one
and a half pages that basically says the
states if you have a better idea about
how to organize your health insurance
markets go for it give us some ideas
well under the only Obama administration
they wrote the regulation about how
thirteen
section 1332 has to work to be so strict
that few states said they're going to
try to do this because they basically
said you can try to do Obamacare exactly
the way we did it but at the state level
and they said that does not help us but
this administration is going to rewrite
those rules to give States a lot more
authority and a lot more power so keep
your eye on that is called state
innovation waivers and it gives States
more flexibility to restructure their
programs
to do things like this family that I was
talking with you about to integrate the
funding streams from all the different
sources around the individual around the
family and allows states to approve
different kinds of health insurance
policies than they're currently being
forced to purchase so that they can
purchase the cover that actually works
for them and their families and they
believe they have the authority to
rewrite this guidance in a way that
actually is going to work for the states
a few states have already submitted two
proposals kind of on a trial brazed
basis Alaska said you know we really
have so many we've got to do something
to lower premiums and they they did a
reinsurance plan that actually lower
premiums by about 20 percent
so Alaska even though it's a very
high-cost state has been able to use
some of this flexibility early on to
lower premiums for the people in those
markets so this is just this was a this
was a graph I'm sure you all have seen
it that a very hardworking staffer for
the Joint Economic Committee drew as
this legislation was passing to really
try to understand it herself all the
boards and the agencies and the new
Commission's and the spending power and
you can see that the Secretary of Health
and Human Services is absolutely at the
center of the universe
in this in this equation two thousand
times it says in the elite in the
legislation the secretary shall or the
secretary may in really making changes
to our health sector patients you can
see him up in the corners patients
doctors Congress even the president or
the four corners relatively irrelevant
the worst thing about this chart is when
I first saw it I thought oh my goodness
what a maze there's no way anybody could
ever understand that after seven years
of being forced to learn what was in
this law I understand every one of these
lines all of the agencies the patient
picori
the patient-centered outcomes Research
Institute I have all of the different
commissions and boards and and
they told me the beginning this is only
a third of the law and I said that's not
possible it's only a third of the law
it's worse than this so we had Congress
has to come back at this we have to free
our economy from the clutches of this
law that if it's allowed to continue is
really going to significantly change the
equation in relationship between
individuals and their government as far
as our freedom is concerned and I if
this PowerPoint is useful to you in any
of your own writing or work I would be
happy to send it to you just send me a
note at Grace Murray at Gaylord or give
me a card afterwards and let me had to
happy to send you the PowerPoint all
these these slides are in the public
domain but it's really we just have to
get back to a system that puts doctors
and patients in charge of health care
sort of charge services and gives you
the power to choose the kind of coverage
options that work for you that do not
bankrupt future generations so thank you
very much I think we have time for
questions Matt yes
you have time for a few questions please
raise your hand and a microphone will be
brought to you thank you
well you but tell us who you are before
you start and where you're from song
Hawk was from Manchester Michigan about
an hour east of here
why didn't senator Murkowski and Collins
get what they wanted it seems to me that
somebody dropped the ball they're saying
they actually did they did they were
they were very close we I met with
Senator Graham and Senator Cassidy on
the 26th of September which is the day I
was pulled to the floor at 10 o'clock at
11 o'clock they had a meeting with
Senator Murkowski the Sarah McConnell
has said it's only Alaska how much can
it cost us give her what she wants and
and they felt that she would have been
there but when she saw that Senator
Collins was absolutely not going to move
on this I think it's an ideology
ideological thing with Senator Collins
from Maine and McCain is just mad at
Trump you know he's mad at Trump he does
not want to give him this victory and so
she wasn't gonna she wasn't gonna move
her about because then it wasn't going
to make any difference but they think
that Senator Murkowski would come along
with a different they need a different
story to tell you know really the first
bills were we're going to do a better
job of allocating federal refundable tax
credits than the Obamacare bill did this
gives him a different story to tell this
says we're gonna put the control back in
the power of the hands of individuals
through the medium of the states rather
than having the federal government be
the know you know know all and do all of
health reform but I think I think she's
get a bowl but I don't know about Rand
Paul either but if it's a different
conversation and they're facing you know
primary opponents I think that we may
have a different different outcome early
next year we're working hard on that we
have another question here yes my name
is Patricia Cox and
from Poplar Grove Illinois I'm wondering
early on when Graham Cassady came out 23
governors are somewhere around that
number were quick to resist this plan
what was the the general nature of their
resistance and some of those are
Republican governors almost all of them
were governor's who had expanded
Medicaid remember this bill gave States
an incentive to put able-bodied adults
many of whom had either the offer or
actually had private insurance to their
jobs to put them on Medicaid and the
federal government would pick up 100% of
the bill outrageous well would still pay
in big states only 50% of the cost for
someone with multiple disabilities with
it with it for a seriously disabled
child 50% but able-bodied adults and
this was all about expanding the role of
government in our health sector and so
these 23 governors didn't want to give
up that huge bucket of Medicaid money
California managed to figure out just
total by coincident totally by
coincidence almost everybody who applied
that was Medicaid eligible in California
wound up applying and being able to
qualify for this hundred percent subsidy
who knew well of course they weren't the
California figured out how to rate who
rigged the rules so that they now
one-third of the people in California
are on Medicaid and so the it's it's
really shocking one third of the people
in Massachusetts I had write a column
for Forbes and I was shocked to see in
these prosperous states how many people
are many in Florida 50% of all births
are paid for through Medicaid we have
got to get control of this program if we
are going to get control of health
spending but these were mostly
Democratic governors who didn't want to
lose their Medicaid money but it's not
sustainable the federal government can't
afford it and it's ultimately actually
our reason I wrote this piece for mess
about Massachusetts even with this match
which goes down to
percent even with that they're saying
they can't afford it and so the states
have got they're ultimately going to
start squealing and when they do they're
gonna have to come to the table and say
okay let's figure out a better deal they
could spend that money so much more
efficiently if they had money Rhode
Island Rhode Island got something called
a global waver it said if you just give
us the twelve million dollar twelve
billion dollars over measured a little
tiny state like Rhode Island could spend
twelve billion dollars on Medicaid over
I think it was five years that they said
we think we'll be able to save money
both for the federal government in the
state's they covered the same number of
people improved services and only spent
nine billion so states hadn't were
control they could get more value for
the bucks they just have to trust
themselves and believe it and it means
to basically be told that we can't
afford this and you saw those why put
those numbers on at the beginning of the
presentation we can't afford this this
is going to bankrupt our country it's
going to rob us of our freedom and we've
got to figure out it's got it it has to
start with entitlement spending and
Medicaid is a big part of the ballgame
so next question
hi Eric Halverson from Birmingham
Michigan thanks so much for being here
um although it probably won't happen
politically what are your thoughts on a
bill to just repeal the Affordable Care
Act and then come back to the table and
a different bill to replace it well that
was the original plan you know they've
had they twice had passed just repeal
legislation and said willing to come
back to replace feeling that that would
force
Democrats to the table so they would be
able to pass something in a bipartisan
nature but there were just too many
Republicans who were worried they
wouldn't be able to do that and even the
full repeal bills still had this
two-year safety net people were going to
be able to keep their coverage for two
years to give Congress a chance to do
the full to do some sort of replace
legislation but it's just you know we
thought that that's what they would be
able to do but it quickly more from
repeal to repeal it
place and the replace part of it is
where they've had such a hard time
building consensus which is why I think
this new platform of Graham Cassity
returning money to empower to the states
gives them a new a new platform to build
a new chassis for which to build new
legislation thank you for that question
my name is Jeff fat Havel thanks for
coming to Hillsdale before it gets my
question I just like to say that I no
longer refer to it as Obamacare I call
it Obama Roberts McCain snow Collins
care but my question is what service is
the right response when talking to our
liberal friends when they explain to me
about how beautiful things work in
Europe and especially Scandinavia about
how they have great outcomes it doesn't
cost them anything
everybody's perfectly happy with it what
sort is the right response when debating
my liberal friends on that topic
thank you yeah I know and any even
Bernie Sanders right he's talking about
the Utopia of Medicare for all first of
all let's just talk about what that
might mean in this country if we were to
do Medicare for all the average couple
in this country over their working life
paying you know taxes into the Medicare
trust fund as though there really were
one it's not trust fund it's a Ponzi
scheme paying Medicare taxes their whole
life will pay about a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars in Medicare taxes over
their working life in their retiree
years they would be expected to consume
about four hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in Medicare services that's a
huge gap that's only filled by a
continuing number of young people
working to pay into the Medicare trust
fund and not consume those services if
we were to have Medicare for all who is
going to make up that deficit it's just
not possible which is why every state in
this country that has tried to do a
single-payer system Colorado had a big
initiative in 2016
trying to figure out how they were going
to do a single-payer system for the
state of Colorado
they found that it would increase taxes
to the point that it would basically
crush their economy it would mean that
everybody with employer insurance would
lose it and they would have to be honest
on a program that looks a lot like
Medicaid and it went down four to one
eighty percent opposed it 20 percent
supported it California is now trying to
figure out how they're going to do a
single-payer system using this third
section 1332 authority but even with all
these federal dollars flowing into the
state they're they're their new budget
for health care would be more than their
entire state budget for all spending on
all programs it's not affordable in this
country it's really not affordable in
these other countries the way that they
do it they ration care in Canada if you
can't find a primary care physician to
take you on you don't have access to any
specialists or any care and about 25
percent of people in some provinces own
and they what do they do they come in
United States we are the safety net with
a safety valve for many people in Canada
people say well one other country should
we emulate Switzerland Switzerland
programs pretty good it's pretty
strictly enforced individual mandate at
the canton level where there's a lot of
a lot of power by local officials to
enforce this mandate Switzerland has six
million people we have 320 million
people and we're a much more diverse
country the UK oh yes you can get all
the care you want it's free in the UK if
you're on the National Health Service
Program and you don't have private
health insurance your chances of getting
the cancer drug that you need to treat
your cancer in time in a timely manner
and getting new drugs that may actually
work are significantly less than in this
country to the point that cancer
survival rates for a number of different
cancers are much much lower in the UK
than they are
it's because they rash and care people
in the UK though don't know any
different
it's the this program has been an effect
since 1948 they don't have a different
option we in this country are used to
choices and we're used to affordable
health insurance and yes there have been
gaps and yes we can fix that but if we
try to do what they have done it either
will bankrupt us as Bernie's plan the
medicare-for-all plan would do or the
California single-payer system or
Colorado single-payer system or we will
crush the innovation we are the
laboratory for innovation for the world
if we weren't producing the new
medicines and the new surgical
techniques and the new medical devices
yes there are other countries doing this
but the innovation is coming from this
country and yes we're paying for a lot
of the innovation for the world some of
them not taking advantage of it but we
this country is the is the engine for
innovation and what we have to figure
out is how do we innovate our way into a
better healthcare financing system and
it's only gonna happen I believe by
devolve power away from Washington to
individuals to have more choices of
coverage and to give those
pharmaceutical companies an incentive to
come up with a much more affordable
version of a drug something that doesn't
cost a hundred and forty thousand
dollars or surgical centers that who can
provide surgeries at a much more
affordable rate as the Oklahoma surgical
center does when people get outside of
the web of regulation in Washington they
are able to come up with more affordable
options but as long as we have Americans
exposed directly to only 11% of those
health care costs it's not going to
happen it's only gonna happen when the
American people when that energy comes
from the bottom up with the people
demanding more affordable coverage and
feeling empowered to purchase it because
they're anemic
some new ways to do that these temporary
policies Association health plans health
reimbursement arrangement financing is a
beginning step but we have to innovate
our way out of this there is no other
country if we're going to be able to
copy and by the way the next thing they
say well health care is a right if they
say that you really have a right to the
time and energy and investment of a
physician who spent maybe millions of
dollars on equipment for his practices I
spoke yesterday with dr. stormy Johnson
former AMA president
you're a diagnostic radiologist from
Metairie Louisiana
he said he's moved two thousand dollars
on two thousand two million dollars on
improved diagnostic equipment for his
for his practice and do we really have
the right to say that somebody can just
walk in and demand access to that
equipment and his services then his
years of training and expertise no we
don't have that we don't have that right
somebody's gonna have to pay him for it
and do we want the federal government to
decide how little he's going to be paid
to the point that he doesn't invest in
that equipment in the future and we wind
up with old technology and no incentive
to have him continue to develop and grow
his practice
[Music]
[Applause]